hey this is Moshe kasher and Natasha
Leggero we just got married six months
ago which we think pretty much makes us
qualified to give love advice and
strangers so that's what we did
we packed up the car hit the road spread
the love yes it's a honeymoon true
if we were to really dance like for real
no one's watching this is what I think
it would look like
I'm so glad you all were watching that
what our pitch is already party or what
ha ha yeah
just kidding um it's gonna be a lot less
like that from me and a lot more like
private liberal arts school up here for
a few minutes uh-huh our only one thing
comes from my I have a trigger because I
was cheated on by some oh yeah that's
your thing yeah and I can't do it yeah I
gotta say that I can't see with other
people when it's like seems okay the
person who I was with would have coffees
and lunches with a lot of girls and a
lot of them he had had past
relationships with and I was like being
cool about it and then it was not and
then it ended up being bad so you don't
love when he has coffee with girls yeah
but I'm not telling him not to have it
I'm telling him so he has coffees and
lunches with guy friends he'll say the
guy's name and when it's been a girl
he'll be like a friend and I'm like whoa
who's so I have asked of him just to
tell me when it's a girl and I recently
was like have you ever slept with her
had a relationship with her and he got
really mad at me for asking that
I started off our conversation by saying
this has nothing to do with you I have a
trigger that I'm trying to get past and
it will go away in time and it would
just help me if there wasn't just a
vagueness and then later and a help you
it wouldn't help you but I would just
like not a friend be like I'm with my
friend Courtney but then you're the one
who's like we 69 ones in 2012 I had a
boyfriend once and I was I thought maybe
something's going on but then I started
like going through his stuff and I
remember I read like bad diary entries
and it made me so upset and none of it
was all kind of his fantasy and it kind
of ruined everything and I always told
myself I'll never look at anyone's email
I just got over it what he got it she
likes to drink bottled water constantly
and instead of like sipping it like a
normal
she'll suck it out of there social
pressure I don't know just like gross
today every time she goes to her water
bottle it's just like oh okay and Sam
what do you have to say about this in
your defense it doesn't sound like that
much of a problem that's true except if
you if you cut the little stuff out then
you you never build up to big stuff like
you know you guys will get married
you'll spend 40 years together and then
one day you'll be in you'll be like an
old woman and you'll be in a rocking
chair and he'll just come in with a side
of frozen side of lamb I told you 40
years ago to stop this I actually feel
better after you guys because I'm like
okay cool it's like oh so I can just
like let this go
the thing about Trust is that it's
either it's either the person's you are
worthy of your trust or they're not the
circumstances around it don't matter
it's like either got asked um do do you
got enough sometimes they're not even
scum they're just too young or something
it's like I know it's like they're just
gonna experience also they say that
something like like 70% of married
couples have a cheating partner oh my
god it's kind of like hey do you think
it is a betrayal that's crazy
it is a betrayal but it's not like six
is such a common Videl thing yeah even
that big of a girl French betrayal the
classic French betrayal is there
anything that Ed could do differently
besides the shirt I guess
he's very passive-aggressive out his
roommates like its roommate broke a dish
so she wrote him a notes
tell him I could be like dude you broke
my - like for like where's my rent check
okay I have an idea okay in the Dasha
how about you guys move in with each
other
no you stop doing that weird thing with
your water that seems very good that
seems great edit Sam we please me thank
you
let me give it what what a give it oh
okay that's so weird
that's so weird that Josh didn't want to
come up